thousands of cannabis industry
professionals are in las vegas for mj
biz con this is the first time it's
actually been held since the pandemic
over the last 18 months the marijuana
industry has made major strides across
the u.s and right here in las vegas
sales in nevada cost 1 billion already
for this year kate houston stopped by
the convention to see the very latest
trends the whole industry shifted
digital zac lipson is the co-founder of
dutchy a company that creates technology
to support e-commerce for dispensaries
people have very big plans in the space
it's really exciting
but you need technology that's going to
be able to grow with you during the
pandemic dispensary sales went from
partially online to fully online as a
result of that a big trend now is
utilizing data and technology to reach
customers we're going to provide tools
to you
to get you through this
to allow you to be more efficient
through the pandemic things like
curbside pickup you know that was it we
spun that out in a couple weeks and it's
a great feature that we still have today
another major topic of conversation the
recent legalization of pot lounges in
nevada the fact that you can buy
cannabis and consume it on site and it's
going to be more akin to a bar than
anything we've seen in this country and
any other state has done chris walsh the
ceo of mj biz says nearly a dozen new
states have legalized marijuana in the
past two years walsh says nevada is now
a leader in innovation by finding an
effective way for social cannabis
consumption we can turn this chapter and
use this as a blueprint this is going to
lead to another evolution
kate houston live local now mj bizcon is
going on through friday afternoon damon
john one of the investors on shark tank
will be giving the keynote address
didn't